well you can call it a reversal of
fortune
more women are now paying alimony to
their ex-husbands
as cbs 2's dana tyler reports this one
has been dubbed
manimony
[Music]
jennifer lopez 10 million dollars
[Applause]
britney spears 40 grand a month
madonna a whopping 76 million dollars
that's how much they have to pay their
exes it's called manimony
when uh a woman has to pay alimony no no
no alimony it's alimony
not manimony okay that's all it is okay
it's not reverse racism it's racism okay
call it what it is use the proper words
i don't like that
and it's not just for the rich and
famous any woman can be forced to pay
this type of spousal support
women today are naturally more dominant
in the workforce than they've ever been
women are now the top earners in a third
of all marriages and when those
marriages fail as 50 percent of them do
women now have a greater responsibility
to pay not only alimony but also
child support it's something this woman
who didn't want to show her face and
embarrass her children
knows all too well i pay him child
support the full amount for three
teenagers for child support
and i pay him alimony the former sales
rep is angry
saying she shouldn't have to pay her
able-bodied ex and it's not because
she's a woman
yo pull out the violence
listen my girl i don't think you're
supposed to pay alimony
i don't but since that's the standard
for the people that are earning more and
it's been like that
for the ages of time and now you're
earning more
then yes you should at the end of the
day
that's what we call equality you wanted
this so we having this
if you want to make more money you
should have all the responsibilities
that come with making more money and
getting married
end of story that's right you're mad
because you're being treated equally to
a man
wow it almost sounds like you don't want
equality what you really want are
special privileges
yeah it almost sounds like when you live
on the first layer and then you get
demoted to the second leg you're like
oh is this what men live like yeah but
i'd rather just live on the first layer
because it was way better
but i also want to make more money which
means i'll be way heavier which means
i'll put more burden on the other layers
but i don't care because
i just want to live my best life okay
yeah you have to give the gold back
that's right
if you're living your life like it's
golden uh-huh and it's too much gold
then fork over that gold
i'm not even for it that hasn't been
equal for
ages yeah but now you're just in that
spot yeah
and i support you girl i don't
understand why i'm paying him a monthly
fee
for nothing what question do you think
we've been asking ourselves well guess
what we forked over that money didn't we
and we're not even talking about the
people that had to
pay uh alimony and child support when it
was not their children yeah we're not
even going to talk about that no
consider yourself lucky that you're
paying for your kids
yeah because it's easy to you know it's
easy to see that it comes out of your
poom boom you're here yeah when a thing
come out
we know what yours yeah here we know
them kids belong
to you because the thing come out your
poom poom
you're here so it's really hard to
disprove
that you're going to pay you're going to
pay for a child
some children that are not yours we know
where they're from
we can see the trail there's a cordon
that comes with it yeah here
so yeah uh at least it's not that you're
paying for kids that are yours
i support you girl i support you make
your money
and then give me my peace divorce
attorney barry weinberger says many of
her female clients are resistant to
paying manimony
and believe it or not some men are
embarrassed to receive it
men are providers right so to collect
alimony is almost kind of counter to
that
but the law is clear and matimony
payments are based on the same criteria
as alimony payments
they'll not only look at the disparity
in income but they'll look at the length
of the marriage
they'll look at the potential for future
income it's the price of being
successful says the sales rep
i don't think it's fair but i've
accepted it i'm not a
person that would begrudge him and i'm
not a vindictive person
but she doesn't have to like it dana
tyler cbs 2 news how you feel about it
i feel great tony's a tiger great
hold up one more video oh nine hold on
hold on when the man
gets more brain you
don't want to start bringing up
but when a woman makes a whole lot more
it's
not when he's making money you don't
want to sign a free no but when you're
making money like oh bring up maybe a
good idea
what is god
what is that bias i believe that's what
it is yes
but the craziest thing is i agree with
you you guys should be signing prenups
if you make a lot more money
and you want to protect your assets i
have no problem absolutely
but just recognize the fact that you've
demonized men for years for that same
sentiment
and i do think it's a little ironic that
the moment that you're in a position of
power
you engage in that same behavior that
you once considered problematic
did you call that ironic like i don't
know
rain on a wedding day
it really sounds like a free ride when
you're already paid no but anyways
that's it for today's video that's all i
got to say
we want to hear your thoughts in the
comments below what do you feel about
this topic do you agree with this ladies
do you disagree
do you think that women should be paying
alimony if they pay more of course you
do because you're a sensible person that
believes in equality
thank you very much for watching it's
like if you know there's ten thousand
spoon and all you need is a fork
[Music]
oh